and so i just noticed a lot of these
teams the really core thing going on
is is ego protection
and nothing else and like you can come
up with all these intellectual arguments
on why actually you know but when you
really talk to someone and you get down
to the core
it's being okay
with getting rejection
hey this is michael seibel with dalton
caldwell welcome to rookie mistakes
we asked yc founders for their rookie
mistakes so we could share them with you
and help you avoid them
here's the first mistake that was
written in
in the beginning
when you're still figuring out your idea
or product
get in as many user or potential user
calls as possible at least one per day
and ideally multiple it seems obvious
but it's something that we personally
failed at in the beginning
don't brainstorm ideas in a silo you
don't know what people want
we have all these ideas in our heads as
founders about what people want that the
moment they are subjected to reality
are embarrassingly wrong
like there's nothing more humbling
there's nothing that makes you feel
shittier
than seeing real people using this thing
that you built that you spent a bunch of
time on and just like ripping it to
shreds and not understanding it or like
using none of the features or clicking
on the wrong thing
it's
horrible so you talking to users is like
the inoculation
against this
spending inordinate amounts of time
doing something that is completely
irrelevant to your end users okay
so
you're suggesting then that i take
surveys right i mean what's the most
efficient way to learn
what my customers want i should survey
them right
so this this this may uh be offensive to
some folks uh listening to this video
but um i don't think that user surveys
are that valuable
when choosing a startup idea surveys are
a useful way to get certain kinds of
feedback
i would think of it as sort of micro
optimizations or trying to choose
directions or say you had four idea four
names for a company you want to choose
which name was the best of the four
choices yeah great run a survey but when
you're looking for fundamental truths or
you're trying to find your first
customer market validation
you want to be
harsher or harder well what does that
mean that means
get someone to give you money for it
do you see how it's a much higher bar to
get someone to pay you money than to
fill out a survey or to get someone to
actually use your thing every day or to
get them to install it
on site
think about how many products that we
would all in a survey say oh that sounds
useful like oh it's
you know very very useful idea that you
have that you would never in a million
years actually pay a dollar for
i think the second thing about a survey
that i've seen really be horrible is
there's a tiny subset of your potential
users who actually have expertise
they've actually tried 27 different
products
this is actually a really important
problem for them
but if you treat everyone you talk to
the same and they felt the same
questions so you never get exposed to
the expertise
and the best example i saw of this was
early days airbnb
airbnb did this fun thing to get users
in the very early days
where they offered people who were
putting their homes online for rental on
other platforms
free digital photos high-res digital
photos back when like digital cameras
weren't a thing yet
in order to list on airbnb
and instead of hiring photographer they
went out they got digital cameras they
went out and they took the photos
and to this day i still remember that
there was one guy
who they met they took photos of his
house
he loved the photos he asked them hey do
you want to sit down for coffee or tea
or whatever they started talking and
then he said you know i've been renting
out my house
on all of the platforms on the internet
for a decade
and i have a notebook of all of my notes
on all the things they do bad and all
the things they do well for the last
decade
do you want to see it
so
in the dalton scenario a he would have
received an email survey like how he
would have signed up for ub not at a
listing not used it would have sent an
email survey like how do you like airbnb
you suggest things to improve right
in the real world example
they got a book of all the things they
needed to do
and again like think about this imagine
you know these guys the founders of
airbnb back in the day
the way they validated the idea was to
ask people
on a survey where they did some user
research they did interview they did a
user interview would you like to rent
your home do you see how
what they could have learned from that
is is like this versus actually trying
to get strangers to rent their home out
to other strangers and all the
like things that popped up trying to
actually make the damn business work do
you see how like
they learned this much from that versus
this much from writing a survey well
dalton it's not even this much
we're not expo we're not we're not
it could be negative
right like it could be negative you're
right well i would never want to use
that because it's uh dangerous so you
need uh you know like
done right you don't make airbnb do you
have another good anecdote about talking
to users about the feature set for
twitch streamers back in the day can you
can you share that story about what how
you created a priority list based on
tell us about that so um
when we were pivoting from justin tv and
twitch um emmett um sheer and kevin lynn
were kind of leading the twitch team
and they took this to heart we had not
done talking users for years they took
this to heart and they basically just
started interviewing video game
streamers and asking what they wanted
and the funniest thing is that at this
point we had built every feature a live
video
social media site could have
we had chat we did messaging we had a
feed we had social media stuff we had
embedding we had every kind of sharing
we were on multiple platforms
and so
they were really surprised when the
first thing people said was
can i stream in higher quality
and we're like
really
that's like you don't want like some big
we'll build you anything like
yeah can i you know what they said
they're like well you know my computer
costs like four grand and i paid for
like the best internet connection in my
neighborhood and i'm streaming this hd
game
and it looks like crap
and we were like huh
well because we built our own
um media server and we were controlling
our old streaming
that was like a like a
an integer like that was like the
easiest
easiest change you could ever make and
like it would cost us incrementally more
but it was like what but like from uh
from a
building product perspective it was very
anticlimactic
and so i think like three days later
like you know we introduced like
you know higher higher you know hd or
something and these people went crazy
they were like
i've never first of all they're like i
never imagined you could do this like i
thought it was some massive technical
issue that was like where you were
screwing us for like a year just because
it was too hard
and like suddenly you fix it and then
two
i've never used the website where i
talked to someone about it and then it
got better
and so um
this kind of started a series of in
hindsight what looked like extremely
obvious things to build right one was i
want my stream to look better
um very quickly too was i'd like to make
money please like can you help me make
money
you guys don't you want a social network
dude don't you want to customize your
page more with different colors and
themes it's like
no but like i'll run ads on my own stuff
it's like what do you mean it's like oh
if you give me a button
where i'll just run a video out on my
own users and i can make money i'll
click it and really but wouldn't that
what
and then once again we already had video
ads like once again it's like [ __ ] like
that's not even hard to build
like
like the hardest thing was like what
what should the button look like
and again dude you were experts you were
running just in how many years in were
you just it was five years in we were
five years into your startup you knew
everything about everything
but then you were like oh yeah i guess
we should talk to some of our users and
they said a bunch of stuff that blew
your minds that none of you would have
thought
and not only did it blow our minds like
the engineers listening should
appreciate it it wasn't hard to build
like we could make them happy
so easily compared to all the other [ __ ]
on our brainstorm list that was like you
know
months long projects
and i was like oh damn
so anyways
clearly um
going a little deep
helps
putting yourself in a situation where
you can have a deep conversation is way
better than anything else
um
we touched on this and i want to bring
up a
a quote because it we can dig a little
bit deeper
a yc finder wrote in
a potential customer's opinion is not
valuable unless they're willing to pay
you
or
use the product regularly
or
share the product with their friends
they call this
financial capital
pay you
time capital usage or social capital
give it to their friends
i think people really struggle with this
because i think it's it's getting at the
core of like a human condition thing
which is we want to be loved if we don't
want to be rejected
and so
you know
getting through all these layers of
defense that you've created for yourself
to protect yourself from rejection is
really hard and it's like
yeah man it's personal work like it's
work you're doing in your head it's not
work you're doing in the external world
and so i just noticed a lot of these
teams the really core thing going on is
is ego protection
and nothing else and like you can come
up with all these intellectual arguments
on why actually you know but when you
really talk to someone and you get down
to the core
it's being okay
with getting rejection
i always like to think about this a
little bit like science
like imagine that you're a
founder oh sorry if you're a founder
imagine you're a scientist right
and you could design one of two
experiments
one experiment that actually tests your
hypothesis
and will give you actual information
about whether your hypothesis is right
or wrong another experiment that doesn't
test the important variable at all
how many founders do we know
who are never testing
the important key hypothesis of their
company
for the exact reason you talked about
because if i know that i'm wrong my ego
shatters or my my investors will hate me
or my co-founders will leave or some
other reason i've told myself for not
just figuring out is the thing i think
true or not
and what i find so surprising is that
some founders just it doesn't occur to
them to think this way you know we the
stripe founders come in and talk last
batch
and we always get founders asking us
about pricing i've got to discount my
product got to make it free early and
duh-duh-duh-duh-duh-duh-duh duh
and the stripe founders said we thought
that startups had a problem accepting
credit cards we thought that all of the
existing products out there back in the
day were too hard to use and it's too
much of a pain in the ass
see now we tested our hypothesis we
built something for developers that was
a lot easier for startups to use and
then we charged more than the
competition for it
now any scientist would say okay well if
we're trying to like test this variable
charging more to figure out whether
startups would use this thing it seems
like a great just
logical test
but for a startup founder that seems
like a crippling decision
and what i loved about the stripe
founders here is that they just went
with the logical test like
they they kind of put their ego to the
side and they said hey
what's the fastest most logical test
that we can run to see if this thing is
something that people want
anyways
so
we've talked about this like
problem this this mistake of like are my
users willing to spend some capital any
kind of capital and using my product
here's here's the last one that i love
um the last one is kind of sometimes
what i call the terrorist user or like
the user that you love more than they
love you so here's the quote from the yc
founder
when the customer you're pitching says
we really love your tech but we can't
pick it up today because x
but we want to use it in our next
project and we'll be in touch soon
um
this is a rejection
they don't want your tech they just said
they loved
they just want you out of their office
this is a don't call me
i'll call you so
how does a founder interpret whether
they're talking to a real customer
or someone who's just trying to be
polite or just trying to move on or
doesn't have the need like how do you
figure out
you we told them to talk to their
potential users how do i figure out what
are they talking to a live one
i think if we
talk about being scientists again like
we did a moment ago
a scientist would be dispassionate
and would say
okay no and they wouldn't think about it
anymore and they would go on to the next
thing
you know dalton i think a lot of the
reason why founders get caught in this
trap is because they were never taught
what sales really is
like they were taught sales in the
context of i would almost argue
argument
like i think what a lot of founders
think sales is is more like what lawyers
have to do to convince a jury
like a jury's
has to be there
and like they're gonna make a decision
and as a lawyer your job is to convince
them one way or the other
i would argue that the best sales people
convincing is really low on the list of
what they're doing
like i might say convincing isn't on the
list of what they're doing
right
i would argue that the best sales people
are spending a lot of their time doing
two things learning and filtering
learning and
filtering it's a successful conversation
with the customer
if they say no quickly and they teach
you about other kinds of customers who
also are going to say no quickly
that's a success
and like filtering out
the customers who will never get to a
yes as soon as possible
is a success
and i think that a lot of founders have
never done sales are like oh no if they
say no that just means that they don't
understand how good my thing is and i
have to explain it better as opposed to
like
no that no is a gift
figure out what you could have asked
them so they would have said no in the
first
three minutes of the conversation
you know so why see we kind of talk
about this as customer validation like
every sales call should start with three
questions that allow the customer to
disqualify themselves from your product
right
a lot of your calls should be ending in
the first five to ten minutes like
you know i don't think we're right for
you now we're happy to call you back
when we can do this this thing or that
thing but i don't think we're right for
you now
and and if enough founders and it's
funny because the themes are all the
same
being willing to say no being willing to
test the core hypothesis oh sorry being
willing to accept a no being willing to
test the core hypothesis not feeling bad
when someone doesn't want your thing
like having
yeah of self-recrimination
and
self-doubt and
you know like you can get really dark
and it's like someone just doesn't want
to buy your thing like who cares
you have to get used to it it's like
lots of people out there
so
um
if we were to wrap this up
this has become commonplace
advice now to talk to your users
and i think that the reason why people
don't do it
and and you know clearly what you've
kind of
played out is they don't do it because
it makes them feel bad
and they don't want to feel bad
and you know here's what i told you
startups
i hope you're passionate about what
you're working on because you're going
to feel bad all the time
like that's what you signed up for
so like don't run don't like like
it's kind of like a marathon runner
being like man i hate that feeling when
my legs are super cramped and i don't
want to run anymore it's like well
you're going to feel that way all the
time
like
you're good because you can deal with
that feeling and stay productive
and stay
logical and stay scientific about what
you're doing i think about
a lot of what you just said in terms of
the trade-off of being an employee
versus being a founder when you're an
employee if you're working at
apple or google
you don't have to worry about any of
this stuff you're like you got 15 layers
protecting you
from external world feedback that you
don't want
you have
several layers of managers telling you
it's all going to be okay and giving you
constructive positive feedback
you have them getting fired when it
doesn't work out right that's their
fault it wasn't your fault you have
company all hands where you can exp you
know like you have all these layers
where your your this is all the stuff
that's filtered out from you man like
this is not your problem when you have a
job when you're a founder there is no
filter and i think people freak out
because they treat being a founder is on
the same
like the same sort of thing as being an
employee they're like oh either i'm
going to work at google or i'm going to
start a startup it's like well
no
this is different
right one of them in one of those things
you're like a worker bee and like you
can just work on your thing and it's
really low stress and like you know
you have to worry about your manager
liking you and stuff like that is this
there's no managers there's no filter
you're just out there dangling in the
wind
and every breeze that comes your way
you're gonna feel
yeah you you the the the inputs that you
experience as a founder are like
completely unfiltered yeah it's just
and and you have to be the person that
tells the people working with you that
it's all gonna be okay you're now on the
role of the filter
like you are the filter not the person
being filtered to
yikes
i think a lot of folks aren't mentally
prepared for this um reality
is tricky when it's not filtered
but i'd argue it's more fun
it's more fun to look at the sky with
your own eyes than to look at a drawing
of a picture of a movie of a da of the
sky like
it's more fun like
you gotta live your life right like
you know
we only get a short time in this earth
so you might as well use your own two
eyes um that's that's at least my
thought on this
all right well this is a great this is a
great wrap up on talking users why and
why it feels like crap